alles neu in österreich erstmals wollen
dort konservative und grüne gemeinsam
regieren
wir müssen leider draußen bleiben
stuttgart sperrt nun auch euro 5 diesel
aus brandursache himmelslaternen drei
frauen haben das feuer im krefelder
affenhaus offenbar unabsichtlich
verursacht
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am 2
januar zusammen mit kristin otto für den
sport auch heute sehr gerne guten abend
für österreichs grüne ist es eine
premiere
sie regieren nun mit in wien die
koalition mit der fdp steht der pakt für
die gemeinsame regierung ist
unterzeichnet vor allem bei den
streitthemen migration und klimawandel
haben sich beide parteien offenbar
zusammengerauft
der ex kanzler wird auch der neue sein
sebastian kurz von der konservativen övp
das bündnis mit seinem letzten
koalitionspartner heinz christian
strache von der rechtspopulistischen fpö
zerbrach an der sogenannten
spitzelaffäre neuer junior partner soll
nun also die grünen werden und ihr chef
werner kogler neuer vizekanzler
auswählen berichtet britta hilpert
es ist für sebastian kurz nichts neues
dem bundespräsidenten die ziele seiner
regierung zu erläutern
neu ist der mann der dazu kommt werner
kogler möglicher erster grüner
vizekanzler aus verantwortung für
österreich nennen sie ihr gemeinsames
regierungsprogramm und kurz betont für
seinen teil thematische kontinuität die
migrationspolitik wird ein herzstück
meiner politik bleiben und mir ist
wichtig dass wir hier eine konsequente
linie fortsetzen
mehrheitlich weiblich ist kurz künftige
minister rieger vier von 15 posten
sollen mit grün besetzt werden sie
bekommen das umwelt und
verkehrsministerium justiz soziales und
gesundheit
jeder partner muss einiges schlucken und
darf bei den eigenen schwerpunkt themen
glänzen
wir haben das verhältnis ausgerechnet ob
es genau 127 entspricht und ich meine
aber das ist gar nicht entscheidend denn
ich habe nicht die grünen sondern wenn
alles gut geht hat österreich geworden
und das ist unser ziel dass dieser
handschlag gelegt hatten viele
österreicher nicht für möglich gehalten
allen voran die ex koalitionspartner von
der fpö
kaum zu glauben dass die grünen
tatsächlich ihre kritische haltung
gegenüber der schwarzen macht gier
abkaufen haben lassen sagte ex
innenminister kickl doch 326 seiten
regierungsprogramm reichen ihn als basis
für das wagnis österreichs erste
schwarz-grüne regierung ja aber am
samstag musste im ganzen noch die grüne
basis zustimmen wird er über den wien
könnte das noch einen stolperstein auf
dem weg zur regierung sein
ein kleiner vielleicht den
unberechenbarkeit gehörte auch in
österreich zum grünen selbstverständnis
aber ich denke mehrheitlich stehen die
grünen hinter dem projekt
regierungsbeteiligung allein schon um
ganz europa zu beweisen dass eine
schwarz grüne regierungskoalition
funktionieren kann
ich denke der eigentliche test verfolgt
erst später der eigentliche test ist die
praxis denn manche grüne punkte sind im
koalitionsvertrag doch eher vage
formuliert die co2 bepreisung zum
beispiel die soll kommen aber es ist
nicht genau klar wann die vp inhalte
dagegen sind eher klar umrissen
es bleibt eine besondere herausforderung
für den alten und neuen bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz diese beiden partner über
die volle legislaturperiode von fünf
jahren zusammen zu halten wird ein
interessantes jahr für österreich vielen
dank britta hilpert libyen seit dem
sturz von machthaber gaddafi ist das
land praktisch in zwei teile zerfallen
und viele ausländische mächte mischen
sich ein
nun will auch die türkei truppen
schicken zwei seiten ringen in dem
rohstoffreichen land und die
vorherrschaft einmal die regierung von
premier saad nicht nur anerkannt von den
vereinten nationen sondern auch
unterstützt von katar der türkei sowie
italien dagegen der abtrünnige general
haffter der seinerseits an die macht
will an seiner seite stehen unter
anderem saudi arabien die vereinigten
arabischen emirate frankreich und
russland weder touches die truppen von
haffter auf dem vormarsch nach tripolis
sie haben grosse teile libyens unter
ihrer kontrolle
doch die hauptstadt konnten sie bisher
nicht eingehen
libyen ist gespalten zwei lager kämpfen
um die macht unterstützt von
ausländischen kräften nun die
entscheidung des türkischen parlaments
soldaten das land zu schicken um die
truppen von regierungschefs arbeit zu
unterstützen
die opposition kritisiert das vorhaben
in libyen sei unsinnig und gefährlich
wann und wie viele soldaten ist sein
werden da steht noch nicht fest
savas ist ein bedrängnis braucht
dringend militärische hilfe
wer braucht bewaffnete boden
unterstützung mit allen dazugehörigen
elementen die spezialeinsatzkräften und
militärischen geräten 2000 soldaten
könnten das vorrücken der haft truppen
auf tripolis stoppen
erdogan sucht partner jüngst besuchte er
tunesien ein nachbarland von libyen
dort war er wohl um unterstützung für
sein militärisches vorhaben tunesien
will aber vorerst neutral bleiben
in dem konflikt geht es der türkei aber
nicht nur um machtfragen vielmehr um
rohstoffe libyen verfügt über wichtige
öl und gasquellen erst im november hat
erdogan mit sat 1 sie abkommen
vereinbart dadurch erhebt die türkei nun
anspruch auf das östliche mittelmeer und
die dortigen erdgasvorkommen
besonders brisant für die türkei das
verhältnis zu russland jüngst
verhandlungen zu syrien jetzt steht ein
neues treffen mit präsident putin an
am 8 januar und dann geht es um libyen
russische sollten da kämpfen dort aber
auf der anderen seite es tut eine
weitere gefährliche konfrontation um
erdgas geht es auch in einem projekt
zwischen israel zypern und griechenland
die drei länder wollen gemeinsam eine
pipeline durch das östliche mittelmeer
bauen
dazu haben die staatschefs beim treffen
in athen ein abkommen unterzeichnet die
pipeline unter dem namen ismet soll
gasvorkommen vor zypern und israel
erschließen und über 2000 kilometer nach
griechenland verlaufen
hoffnung für viele vw fahrer die im
diesel skandal eine entschädigung wollen
volkswagen verhandelt jetzt mit dem
bundesverband der verbraucherzentrale
über ein
vergleich die verbraucherschützer
vertreten hunderttausende autofahrer die
sich einem musterverfahren angeschlossen
haben beide seiten betonen aber die
verhandlungen stünden am anfang
ob es zu einem vergleich kommt sei offen
und auch in stuttgart geht es zu
jahresbeginn wieder um den diesel
dort ist die luft inzwischen durch die
umweltzone deutlich besser geworden die
feinstaub grenzen werden eingehalten
doch bei den stickoxid werten gibt es
noch nachholbedarf und deshalb wird das
fahrverbot jetzt auf euro 5 diesel
ausgeweitet für sie werden die
wichtigsten zufahrten in die stadt
gesperrt viele betroffene können ihre
autos aber nachrüsten
andreas linke eine neue stufe von
fahrverboten in stuttgart nun auch für
euro 5 diesel die gerichte hatten den
schärferen luftreinhalteplan gefordert
wir müssen jetzt ab 120 120 vier
strecken für euro 5 und schlechter
sperren weil wir auch damit hoffen dass
wir vielleicht keine gesamte innenstadt
zone sperren müssen kontrollen sind
derzeit nicht vorgesehen so enthält das
verbot viel symbolik
ausnahmen gelten für anlieger und
nachgerüstete diesel die nachrüstung mit
hardware komponenten ist nun auch
möglich klaus beck aus stuttgart hat als
einer der ersten sein mercedes damit
ausgestattet und dabei daimlers 3000
euro prämie genutzt nach langer
unsicherheit hängend von der
autoindustrie kam nichts und
ja und jetzt muss man sagen ist so schön
dass der daimler hier zugesagt hat für
modelle von mercedes volkswagen volvo
und bmw gibt es nachrüstmöglichkeiten
allerdings nicht von den herstellern
sondern von externen zulieferern mit
unseren systemen reduzieren wir die
emissionen um rund 80 prozent im
gegensatz dazu schaffen die software
updates im idealfall vielleicht
reduktion um 7 prozent und damit leisten
wir eben einen beitrag zu einer 2
minderung und nachgerüstete diese müssen
auch mögliche künftige fahrverbote nicht
fürchten nach australien
dort brennt es weiter heftig die lage
spitzt sich sogar noch zu in new south
wales lassen die behörden jetzt diesen
bereich evakuieren
auch im benachbarten bundesstaat
victoria sollen sich die menschen in
sicherheit bringen besonders dramatisch
die lage in märkte wegen der feuer waren
dort rund viertausend menschen von der
außenwelt abgeschnitten
thomas garcia inmitten all der wütenden
feuer ein stiller inniger moment endlich
die marine ist da bringt lebensmittel
bewohner touristen tage lang waren alle
hier eingeschlossen
wir können heute wohl 500 menschen aus
manacor rausholen aber das wollen wohl
gar nicht alle mit gehen bleiben beides
schwierig wer aufbricht und dazu sind
tausende aufgerufen kommt nicht wirklich
voran und sprit ist knapp wer bleibt
bleibt in gefahr und bekommt immer mehr
probleme
es gibt kein wasser keinen strom das
abwasser steht was sollen wir tun
dreht der wind wird es gefährlich für
mein haus es geht hier wirklich ums
überleben
denn die flammen fressen sich voran
haben land und gut zurück bleiben bruce
ruinen ruinierte existenzen nun erst
lässt sich der premier blicken die feuer
brannten schon da weilte scott morrison
im urlaub jetzt schlägt in flammen
bewahrt entgegen warum hatten wir hier
nur vier feuerwehr trucks in unserer
stadt
du bist hier nicht willkommen du
mistkerl dann geht er sagt hilfe komme
was aber nun tun gegen diese
feuersbrunst am samstag kommt noch neue
hitze australien glüht und bleibt in
angst unter einem ganz anderen
wetterextrem leidet derzeit indonesien
nach überschwemmungen sind dort
mindestens 29 menschen ums leben
gekommen
viele weitere werden noch vermisst rund
um den jahreswechsel hatte es
stundenlang und extrem stark geregnet
hochwasser und erdrutsche waren die
folge viele stadtteile der hauptstadt
jakarta sind überflutet zehntausende
mussten in notunterkünfte gebracht
werden
eine heftige debatte über gewalt aus dem
linksextremen milieu hat die silvester
nach den leipzig ausgelöst
im stadtteil connewitz wurden
bereitschaftspolizisten angegriffen mit
steinen flaschen feuerwerkskörper
die situation eskalierte immer mehr ein
polizist wurde schwer verletzt
innenminister seehofer sagte der vorfall
zeige dass menschenverachtende gewalt
auch von links extremisten ausgehe
thomas bärsch berichtet es war am
neujahrsmorgen gegen 0.15 als die lage
am connewitzer kreuz im leipziger süden
eskaliert als die polizei versuchte
randalierer festzunehmen attackierten
diese die beamten mit wurfgeschossen
aber ist es passiert dass ein kollege so
getroffen wurde dass er bewusstlos zu
boden ging und dann am boden liegend
auch noch attackiert wurde
unsere kollegen haben versucht den zu
bergen dass sie sehen auch gelungen aber
auch beim bergen des kollegen sind sie
attackiert worden
der beamte musste zion not op ins
krankenhaus demonstrationen im leipziger
süden werden oft von gewaltausbrüchen
begleitet die connewitzer am tag danach
wir haben die mandalas muss gesehen
daher letzte nacht stattgefunden hat und
stellen uns die frage warum leipzig ist
traumhaft schöne füße habe ich das
gefühl die polizei so viel tut als wenn
ich bin mit dem hubschrauber kreist das
heißt dort werden die streiche möbel
sondern auch kölner disco auch juliane
nagel von der linkspartei macht die
einsatzkräfte mit verantwortlich sie
fragte im internet warum die polizei das
viertel nicht einfach verlassen sondern
behelmt durch die menge rennen und
feuerlöscher
diesmal hat man sehr anonyme polizei die
behelmt und in voller montur auf der
straße stand gesehen und die dann auch
ohne rücksicht auf verluste am
vorgegangen ist im internet gelegte
aufnahmen von polizei kameras frühere
einsätze zeigen welches gewaltpotenzial
der polizei im leipziger süden mitunter
entgegenschlägt den vorwurf zu
eskalieren weist sie zurück
wir haben wir leider in den vergangenen
jahren in unterschiedlichem maß negative
erfahrung gesammelt und dessen müssen
wir dort von vornherein da sein um
straftaten zu verhindern
die polizei spricht von organisierten
angriffen in der silvesternacht das lka
ermittelt auch wegen versuchten mordes
und noch einmal zur silvesternacht in
krefeld drei frauen eine mutter und ihre
erwachsenen töchter wollen das neue jahr
stimmungsvoll begrüßen lassen so
genannte himmelslaternen aufsteigen und
lösen damit das verheerende feuer im
affenhaus des zoos aus da ist sich die
polizei inzwischen ziemlich sicher das
problem die lampen aus in den himmel zu
schicken ist in deutschland verboten
kaufen kann man sie aber trotzdem ralph
goldmann berichtet blumen und kerzen vor
dem eingang des krefelder zoos noch
immer trauern die menschen um die
getöteten affen und können auch zwei
tage danach kaum fassen was passiert ist
jeder in krefeld den zoo kennt es
traurig und über die grenzen hinaus
natürlich und
etwas schreckliches passiert es ist
immer ganz schlimm egal wo es passiert
ich bin gestern schon fast den ganzen
tag hier gewesen weil ich alleine die
trauer nicht aushalten konnte
ich hatte mir hat gut getan dass wir
viele trauernde waren das affenhaus war
in der silvesternacht komplett
niedergebrannt die tiere wurden im
schlaf von den flammen überrascht unter
ihnen auch der 48 jahre alte massa das
älteste gorilla männchen europas nur
zwei tiere überlebten als ursache gilt
eine solche himmelslaterne die das dach
in brand setzte eine 60-jährige hatte
fünfter von gemeinsam mit ihren beiden
töchtern in der nähe aufsteigen lassen
ganz normale bürgerliche menschen
eigentlich sehr vernünftig wirkend auch
verantwortungsbewusst wirken und sie
dachten dass es zu silvester erlaubt sei
diese läuft einsteigen zu lassen nach
einem tödlichen brand vor zehn jahren
sind sie aber in deutschland verboten
sie sind aber dennoch weiterhin in
vielen online shops im internet
erhältlich die frauen werden mit einem
strafverfahren rechnen müssen der
vorwurf fahrlässige brandstiftung bei
einer verurteilung droht ihnen eine
geldstrafe oder bis zu fünf jahren haft
ja hat er schnitt zum sport da hat ein
paradiesvogel aus schottland erstmalig
die darts wm gewonnen das ist die eine
richtig schöne überraschung ich wurde
als clown bezeichnet aber wer zuletzt
lacht lacht am besten so peter wight
nach seinem klaren wm triumph über
titelverteidiger fand herren aus den
niederlanden im tollhaus ally pally in
london
der neue weltmeister zuerst gerührt dann
motiviert bis in die bunten haarspitzen
seinem finalgegner michael von werben
seit sechs jahren weltranglisten-erster
schick peter wright eine kampfansage für
das neue jahr
wir werden auch einige schlachten
schlagen vielleicht bekommt michael auf
seine revanche habe ich werde versuchen
ihn als nummer eins der welt abzulösen
neun major final hatte der 49 jährige
gegen von gern verloren gestern dann der
siebte wm titel in einem hochklassigen
match mit 2 0 sätzen in führung von
werfen gelang der ausgleich bevor der
schotte sich absetzen und mit 7 zu 3 das
spiel für sich entscheiden konnte der
überraschungssieg des paradiesvogels
zeit passend zu dieser wm
bei der auch fällen cherop mit siegen
gegen die männliche konkurrenz für
weltweite schlagzeilen gesorgt hatte
die handball nationalmannschaft startet
in die heiße vorbereitungsphase auf die
europameisterschaft die in einer woche
beginnt das team um kapitän uwe
gensheimer traf sich am mittag in
frankfurt am main torwart andreas wolf
sagte worauf es nun ankommt
insgesamt als die müssen wir eben dieses
gefühl aufbauen dass wir dass wir eine
einheit sind dass wir zusammen die
europameisterschaft gewinnen wollen und
dass wir eben einfach geil halt auf das
turnier in uns entfacht und dies klappt
er bereits sehr gut bei den deutschen
skispringern rund um den aktuellen
tournee zweiter karl geiger
eindrucksvolle gelassenheit zur halbzeit
der bundestrainer ein gefragter
gesprächspartner am letzten ruhetag
dieser tournee während seine mannschaft
entspannen kann zeigt stefan horngacher
wie pragmatisch aller dem dritten
springen in innsbruck entgegensehen der
call ist topfit der uns in auto fit und
wir springen einfach bei der wm im
vergangenen jahr gewann geiger am
bergisel silber im einzel und gold im
team und mit seiner aktuellen form kann
er derzeit ohnehin auf jeder chance
bestehen
wir springen einfach china die quali von
innsbruck morgen mittag live hier bei
uns in die kann man sich auch gut
ansehen christin denn draußen regnet es
morgen und in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen soll es am wochenende
auch schneien
die einzelheiten hat gleich katja
honnefer das war es von uns danke ihnen
für ihr interesse
claus kleber freut sich im heute journal
um drei viertel 10 auf sie und wir
hoffen dass sie morgen und 19 uhr wieder
dabei sind
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren und
frohes neues jahr auch heute saßen
wieder viele von ihnen im strahlenden
sonnenschein andere im dichten nebel wie
hier im donautal
jetzt ändert sich das wetter dann von
westen kommen regen wolken heran
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen auf
5 grad am niederrhein und bis minus 8
grad an der unteren donau
es kann also überall glatt sein vor
allen dingen in der mitte da fällt
nämlich nochmal nieselregen auf
gefrorenem boden im nordwesten kommen
schon die neuen regenwolken an und die
breiten sich morgen vormittag bereits
richtung osten aus und erreichen die
kieler bucht zum beispiel das sauerland
und auch die mosel
in süddeutschland beginnt der tag morgen
freundlich zwischen dem bayerischen wald
und dem oberrhein und auch am nachmittag
können wir hier im südosten noch eine
gewisse chance auf sonne haben sonst
aber setzt sich der regen weiter fort
erreicht rügen den spreewald und auch
den main
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen vier grad an der unteren donau
und elf grad am niederrhein und dazu
nimmt der wind durch zu und dreht von
süd westlichen immer mehr auf
nordwestliche richtungen und an der
küste sind stürmische böen dabei am
samstag sinkt die schneefallgrenze in
den östlichen mittelgebirgen bis 600
meter deutlich ruhiger geht es dann ab
sonntag weiter schöne ab noch